uh welcome thank you all for coming i'm
matthew spaulding associate vice
president dean for hillsdale college
here in washington dc welcome to the
allen kirby center for constitutional
studies and citizenship uh this place is
an extension of the teaching mission of
hillsdale college which provides sound
learning the defense of civil and
religious liberty
and the college has been doing that
since its founding in hillsdale michigan
in 1844
we gather at a time of great turmoil by
which i don't mean we are somewhere
between iowa and new hampshire
the turmoil we face has to do with what
amounts in my opinion to a new form of
government that is all around us
the keys to our great success the
country are the principles at its root
found in the declaration of independence
equal rights and consent
and the framework for government
provided by the united states
constitution
in that constitution delegate powers
derived not from government but from the
consent to the governed are separated
and divided so as to provide for checks
and balances against the accumulation of
power
which the founders federalist papers
thought was the very definition of
tyranny
each branch is vested with distinct
powers responsibilities having to do
with
legislating executing and adjudicating
the law
yet today here we are government is
bigger than ever spends more than ever
and acts increasingly without limits
we are ensnared by a vast web of its
rules and regulations
mostly work of innumerable agencies and
departments under the president
many actual decisions of law making most
in many ways
previously the responsibility of our
elected legislators are being made by
unelected bureaucrats whose rules have
the full force and authority of laws
promulgated by congress
there of course is a longer story here
having to do with the politics of the
20th century
the rise of progressivism liberalism in
the modern administrative state
progressives thinkers in both political
parties i might add wanted to shift
authority away from policy uh in
political decision makers in favor of
expert rule
but the main problem is that for too
long
too many congresses have created these
bureaucracies to carry out their wishes
while at the same time delegating to
them legislative powers in the form of
broad regulatory authority
that the president united states is
exerting newfound quote unquote powers
given the tempting amount of authority
delegated to and claimed by those
offensively under his control
should come as no surprise
we have just come to the point where
modern presidents have figured out how
to use those powers
but it's a dangerous system excuse me a
dangerous symptom of the bureaucratic
rule that is currently overwhelming us
replacing our constitutional form of
government
much government occurs outside consent
is increasingly irresponsible and has
created an imbalance in our
constitutional structure
the only way to reverse this trend
of a diminishing legislature
is for congress to rebuild itself
strengthening its constitutional muscles
in our separation of power system
that's the solution envisioned by our
founders consistent with popular consent
a stronger legislative branch would go a
long way towards making the role of
government a political question rightly
as it should be subject to election
rather than executive fiat or judicial
decree
regardless of who the next president is
and what political party they belong to
the solutions for congress is the
coequal branch of government to regain
its legislative authority
bringing consent and responsibility back
to government through better law making
upfront and oversight after the fact
and the one place where that power is
not entirely lost by any means and where
is there a great opportunity for gaining
leverage over an unchecked executive
is congress's power of the purse
regular legislative order
authorizing appropriating overseeing the
operations of government
will do more than anything else to
restore the article one powers of
congress
done well it will also prevent congress
from continually getting cornered in
large messy and unacceptable omnibus
budgets
this project article one project
is a bicameral effort of house and
senate conservatives develop an agenda
to strengthen and reclaim congress's
constitutional powers
it will focus on reclaiming the powers
purse
restoring congressional authority over
regulators and regulations
in reigning in executive discretion
the goal of the project is to
reconstitutionalize the federal
government by rebuilding congress
as the legislative branch
the first among equals
in order to secure our liberty provide
opportunity and promote american
self-government
hillsdale college is pleased to
contribute to this project and host its
launch
here at our facility and we commend its
work
we will have some brief remarks this
morning by a few speakers
uh to be followed by two panels hosted
by jim capretta of aei and evolving
national affairs
for right now i'm very happy to turn the
podium over to a scholar of the
constitution a practitioner of the law
and a friend senator mike lee of utah
good morning and thank you very much
matt uh thanks to all of you for being
here uh for this event that i've been
very excited about for some time it's
all together fitting that we should have
this event here
and i i'm honored and humbled that we're
holding it just underneath this
beautiful painting this wonderful
depiction of the miracle at philadelphia
the only downside is that this painting
is a little bit intimidating for me
because when i'm standing in front of it
i feel like they're looking down at me
as if to say
you're doing it wrong
as if to say uh we specifically said in
article one section one clause one all
legislative powers here and granted
shall be vested in a congress
you're doing it wrong because other
people are making the laws but that's
after all why we're here today
today's event is the official launch
of the article one project
it's also a fitting reflection of what
our project is all about
in the speeches and the panels that
we'll follow
you'll hear from nine conservative
policymakers about how they intend to
help fix
what's wrong with washington
and help us change the way we have
departed from the constitution to
restore the constitutional structures
and protections
and you're going to see an approach to
policy making in stark contrast to the
way that bills are so often written
today
that
is an open collaborative process
and an ideas driven process
this is the article one project in a
nutshell
it's a new network of house and senate
conservatives working together on a new
agenda
of government reform
and one that focuses on congressional
rehabilitation
the premise of the article one project
is very simple
the federal government's broken
and congressional weakness is to blame
congressional acquiescence is at the
very heart of the problems that we face
in washington
the authors of the constitution made
congress the most powerful of the
federal government's three co-equal
branches
congress was designed both as the most
powerful and is the most accountable to
the people and it was no coincidence
that it occurred in this fashion
consent of the govern in any republic
depends on transparent policy making
within representative institutions
congress's embrace of this mandate is
part of what has made america
both successful
and also exceptional
but if there's one thing politicians of
every
political party and of every ideology
tend to agree on
it's that hard work and accountability
are inconvenient they're rarely easy in
fact they never are they weren't
designed to be
they perform a different but even more
important function
and so over the course of the 20th
century and accelerating into the 21st
century
congress has handed many of its
constitutional responsibilities
over to the executive branch
increasingly harmful federal laws
are increasingly written
by people who never stand for election
a process is contrary to those provided
for in the constitution and indeed with
the explicit purpose of excluding the
american people from their government
and
shielding
policymakers from popular accountability
this part of it
is not a bug it is in fact a feature and
it's a feature that has to be reversed
executive overreach is an enormous
problem but it's a problem
largely in fact almost entirely of
congress's own making
under houses senate's presidents and
supreme courts of every
conceivable partisan combination
congress has recast itself
as the backseat driver
in american politics
today the vast majority of federal laws
upwards of 95 percent
are passed not by the house and senate
and signed by the president but instead
they're imposed unilaterally
by unelected executive branch
bureaucrats
at the same time congress's budget
process is almost entirely broken down
most federal spending
has been put on autopilot effectively
authorized without a vote
meanwhile fiscal oversight deliberation
and reform are a bipartisan charade of
sorts
this upending of our constitutional
order
has led not only to bad policy but also
to deep
and legitimate public distrust
in our governing institutions
this dysfunction is a large and a
growing problem for the american
republic
and for conservatives it represents
something like a crisis for at least two
reasons
first conservatives believe
in constitutionalism and the rule of law
as such
as bulwarks for protecting freedom and
justice in our society
and second
this massive wholesale transfer
of law making power from congress to the
executive branch
unmistakably tilts the policy-making
field
rigging the law-making process to
benefit the wealthy and the
well-connected at the expense of
everyone else and perhaps most
noticeably at the expense of america's
poor middle class
when elected representatives in congress
tied their own hands and empower
unelected bureaucrats to make our laws
in fact to make the overwhelming
majority of our laws measured by volume
measured by most measures that are
available here it unavoidably thwarts
the kinds of policies that conservatives
tend to advocate that is policies that
limit the size and scope of government
and by so doing protect the equal rights
and opportunities available to all
americans so it's no wonder congress's
job approval ratings
are at historic lows you know most polls
put our approval ratings at somewhere
around 10 which makes us a slightly
less popular
uh uh then um fidel and raul castro in
america
and it makes us only slightly more
popular than the influenza virus which
is rapidly gaining on us
in many ways we're not even doing our
job
and the nation is paying the price
but there is some good news
what a week congress has broken
a strong congress can fix
and a strong congress will fix
the constitutional powers
necessary to put a representative
accountable
federal government back to work for the
american people are still right there in
the constitution they're still right
there
in article one of our governing document
ready to be reasserted
all that remains is for us to assert
them properly
that is exactly why we're launching the
article one project here today
the purpose of the project is to develop
advance and ultimately enact an agenda
of meaningful structural reforms to
strengthen congress by reclaiming its
constitutional legislative powers that
today are being improperly delegated to
and ultimately exercised by
the executive branch
specifically a1p
will focus on restoring congressional
power in four key areas that are at the
core
of washington dc's broken status quo
first
reclaiming congress's power of the purse
second
reforming legislative cliffs
third
reasserting congressional authority
over regulations and over regulated
pours
and finally
curbing executive discretion
my colleagues will talk in more detail
about these four pillars of the article
one uh of the article one project that
we're forming today
and they'll explain
what a one p seeks
is not so much to change congress
as to revive it you see congress as it
exists congress as it was created
congress as it was provided for an
article one of the constitution has the
power to do all these things we're just
reviving it we're just restoring that
which has been diminished over time that
which has been clouded by other things
to make it once again live up to its
founding purpose to be the driving force
in federal policy making
not for the sake of the ambitions of any
individual politician
or even the collective ambitions of all
federal politicians but rather to
protect and empower the american people
they represent
our goal here
is simply to make congress once again
responsible
both in the sense of doing
performing our constitutional duties and
also
performing those duties transparently so
that our fellow americans can hold us
accountable
for the choices we make on their behalf
all that stands between today's broken
status quo and a government of
by and for the people is the will of
congress to finally step up and do its
job
for decades congress has done nearly
everything in its power to do exactly
the opposite it's done everything it
possibly can everything it can think of
to avoid doing its job
to surrender its constitutional powers
to the executive branch to have somebody
else make the law
and the country and the american people
have suffered tremendously as a result
but with these nine lawmakers
their collective
and innovative ideas for reform and
their endless supply of political
courage
and energy
we have the power to change that
it is truly an honor to be part of this
effort and i look forward to standing
side by side with this group of
lawmakers
in many future battles on capitol hill
few people in congress have been
fighting this fight
as long
or as successfully as chairman jeb
hensarling
it's been a privilege working with him
on a1p and it's my privilege
to hand the podium over to him thank you
well thank you mike thank you um
for the honor of working with you yet
again some of you know that um
mike and i just finished a huge battle
against corporate welfare
it could have gone a little better
but it's time for another battle and
perhaps even a more important one in the
short time that senator mike lee has
been in washington
uh what a great fighter what a great
champion what a crusader for liberty and
the constitution he has proven to be
and i'm glad to renew our partnership
yet again
on this incredible important project
i'm also honored to be on this uh turf
hillsdale also indispensable to the
cause of liberty all the great things
that they have done thank you for
hosting
uh math this event and yes it is
intimidating to speak in the shadow
of this painting
and as a reminder though that just this
last summer my wife and i took our 12
year old son and
13 year old daughter to independence
hall in philadelphia
it is important for my wife and i that
our child children learn about the cause
of liberty learn about american
exceptionalism
and as often as i've been to
independence hall it's still stirring to
walk in the footsteps
of the patriots
but when you're there you're reminded of
the stories of what america was
at that point in our history
there was crushing debt
there was rampant inflation in our young
nation
there are bitter trade disputes
some in massachusetts even threaten
secession
in retrospect maybe not such a bad idea
but
i sense that
moment has passed
patrick henry you may recall boycotted
proceedings madison and general henry
knox had to travel to mount vernon to
talk washington into even attending the
event
edmond randolph worried as the delegates
gathered quote are we not on the eve of
war which is only prevented by the hopes
from this constitution
indeed much despair and anguish ruled
the day and more than once the entire
enterprise depicted in this wonderful
painting seemed destined for failure but
it didn't fail
it didn't fail because the spirit of 76
was still alive and well and resounded
echoingly in those hallowed halls so the
seeds of american exceptionalism that
were surely planted in 1776
took firm root in 1787
it is then
that we the people truly secured our
liberty in the course of human events
would never be the same
in his penultimate statement of the
union message president reagan reminded
us of these three simple words we the
people
make all the difference between our
constitution and the constitutions of
other nations
in those other constitutions he said
quote the government tells the people
what they are allowed to do
and our constitution we the people tell
the government what it can do
and that can only do those things that
are listed in that document and know
others
so the sheer genius of our constitution
is framework of checks and balances
limited enumerated powers coequal
branches of government secured our
fundamental rights and gave rise to the
freest most prosperous civilization the
world has ever known
but put it mildly over the years many of
these principles have been neglected and
others outright abandoned
instead of a limited government
operating from a clearly defined
enumeration of powers we have a levison
that is metastasized into the nation's
largest creditor debtor employer
property owner tenant insurer healthcare
provider pension underwriter and i would
go on but i've run out of breath
instead of checks and balances we have
the president's pin
and phone
instead of three co-equal branches of
government we have seen the ominous rise
of the unaccountable fourth branch of
government namely agency government
it is a reminder that although we have
ominous foreign threats to our safety
and security that lead the nightly news
threats that emanate from far away
capitals like moscow
damascus and tehran we cannot and must
not lose sight
of the domestic threats to our freedom
and liberties that emanate from another
capital city far closer to home
namely washington dc
some of these domestic threats may
appear less evident in the short term
but over time they are as corrosive to
our constitution and to our national
well-being
as individuals and as a nation
none of us can ever afford to lose sight
of madison's famous warning that quote
there are more instances of the
abridgement of the freedom of the people
by gradual and silent encroachment by
those in power than by violent and
sudden use of patients
that's why we're gathered here today to
launch the article one project a new
network of conservatives working
together to reclaim congress's rightful
constitutional role i'm privileged to
co-chair this effort i'm honored to
serve with my colleagues in this effort
as members of congress we have no more
important jobs to take more seriously
than upholding the constitution yet i do
not recall ever in my lifetime when i
have seen the constitution under as much
assault as it is today
just in the last few years we've seen an
american president unilaterally create
new law to know existing law and even
declare the senate in recess when it was
not so just so he could install
political functionaries into top
government positions
clearly that whole advice and consent
foolishness can be such a bother to a
president
this from a man who frequently reminds
us that he used to be a constitutional
law professor
i have no doubt that his former students
have a valid cause of action for
teaching malpractice
and i trust the statute of limitations
has not run
the adherence of this governing
philosophy so at odds with america's
founding principles call themselves
progressive
as my good friend speaker paul ryan has
said the ironic thing about
progressivism is that it's so terribly
old-fashioned
for progressives believe the only only a
certain class of people a class to which
they of course belong has the duty and
the responsibility to hold political
power and we the rest of us we the
people must yield to their expert
management for our own good because as
one architect of obamacare said the rest
of us are just too stupid to know better
how could we possibly know what health
insurance plan is best for us what kind
of mortgage we need or even how much
water we should use to flush our toilets
to progressives the constitution is a
huge inconvenience
herbert crowley a leading voice of the
early progressive movement and
co-founder of the new republic magazine
said as much when he stated that the
progressive vision of government quote
legislates but without being a
legislature it administers but without
being an executive it adjudicates but
without any power of attaching final
construction to the law it is simply a
convenient means of consolidating the
divided activities of the government for
certain practical social purposes
madison and federalist number 47 had a
different take on the notion when he
wrote the combination of all power
legislative executive and judiciary in
the same hands may justly be pronounced
the very definition of tyranny
the seat of this form of tyranny was
planted during the wilson administration
bloomed during fdr's new deal became
overgrown in lbj's great society has now
reached crisis proportions under
president obama
this century-long progressive expansion
of unconstitutional government has
unleashed the modern regulatory state as
we know it today extremely powerful
exceedingly intrusive imperiously opaque
baffinly bureaucratic and alarmingly
unaccountable
now congress has been no innocent
bystander during all of this part of the
reason that we have this out of control
regulatory state is because for far too
long congress has outsourced its
constitutional responsibilities
as we all know article one section one
of our constitution states quote all
legislative powers here in granted shall
be vested in a congress
thus when congress delegates its
fundamental legislative authority to an
unaccountable unelected bureaucracy it
is arguably acted in an unconstitutional
manner this
self-enfeeblement must end because when
congress allows its authority to be
usurped the people's right to both
self-government and due process is
undermined instead of being governed by
the rule of law citizens become more and
more governed by the rule of law rulers
and the discretion of regulators
the citizens right to carefully
deliberate proposed legislation through
their representatives in congress
becomes reduced to nothing more but a
notice in comment period when they are
permitted to merely lodge complaints and
suggestions all of which the unelected
bureaucrats are free to ignore all of
which the unelected bureaucrats may use
to retaliate
the result it is ocean now not congress
that governs over workplace safety it is
the epa now not congress that governs
our air quality it is hhs now not
congress that governs over our health
care and most alarmingly to our economic
opportunity and economic liberty it is
bureaucratic progeny of dodd-frank that
now rules over our financial markets so
where do we go from here
first congress congress must reaffirm
the primacy of congressional authority
and of all the tools that we can use to
address this none is greater than the
power of the purse this article one
responsibility is the most potent and
effective instrument we have to hold the
executive accountable
to paraphrase a rather colorful texan
president lindsen baines johnson if you
grab a bureaucracy by its budget it
hearts and minds will soon follow
for years congress has slowly
surrendered its constitutional power
over federal spending and our first
priority must be to reclaim it
to do so congress needs to seriously
reform the budget process and come up
with an entirely new one
earlier in my career national review
once called me representative budget
reform so i am eager to start this work
in earnest yet again
in addition to budget reform congress
must also in the practice of delegating
this law making authority to the
unaccountable unelected agency
government
no more passing vague laws to direct
agencies to fill in the blanks
so for example the reigns act which has
already passed the house would introduce
both constitutionally and accountability
constitutional accountability into the
system by requiring that congress
approve any major new legislations the
act is simple the act is profound and
its passage must be part of this
incredibly important effort so ladies
and gentlemen let us each today take our
stand for freedom as an olden time when
the brave patriots stood for freedom at
independence hall
that remarkable group who dared to
believe they could start the world all
over again
so let us each today as part of this
article one process let us dare to
believe that we can again secure the
blessings of liberty for coming
generations in america let us rededicate
ourselves to article one of the
constitution thank you
well since today is old partners day it
is my pleasure
to introduce another old partner senator
jeff flake
uh when jeff served in the house we took
on the earmark wars and as i recall we
lost every single battle but we won the
war
and we have lost another a number of
battles in fighting for the constitution
but we will win this war
and i know of no happier warrior for the
cause of freedom and liberty and senator
jeff flake my friend from arizona
senator flake
well thank you jeb
i have to correct that
of all the hundreds and hundreds of
times we went to the floor to challenge
earmarks we did win one there was
one vote that came but the war followed
and we we did
get rid of legislative earmarks now the
problem is uh what goes on in the
executive branch and with the agencies
and i
i uh will
not uh
try to go over what has been gone over
so well by mike lee
and jeb hensling two of my legislative
heroes here
but uh let me just talk about
regulations for a minute
jeb talked about the power of the purse
and how to
to
get our article one authority back
if anybody wants to uh to know
how bad it's gotten in terms of
of what the executive branch is able to
do
is look at the publication federal
register
it's published monday through friday
runs anywhere from 100 to
over a thousand pages every day
it's comprised almost entirely of newly
noticed regulations
it is an alarming snapshot of
washington's bureaucracy
growing
and
it's a sad problem
of congress's ever diminishing role
in the governing process
on average more than four thousand new
regulations come into effect each year
another twenty seven hundred are posed
uh these are crafted by unelected
bureaucrats
and administration run agencies
and we we have to
have to change this equation
as jeb mentioned the power of the purses
is really
the way to do that
there is no way
that we can win the political battle
when we only have one bill at the end of
the year and have an up or down vote
you simply lose any leverage you have
and we've got to get back to
when we pass appropriations measures one
by one
and therefore can have some rain over
the legislature i'm sorry the regulatory
process let me just give you
two
brief examples of how bad it's gotten
i'm from arizona
we sometimes have dust storms that roll
through
uh
they completely uh
come in and you can't see your hand in
front of your face for a while these
dust storms have been coming through
arizona
for
decades
and centuries probably millennia
my family has been in arizona five
generations
these dust storms have always been there
but now uh they're regulated as if they
were some call some how a man-made
phenomenon and every time a dust storm
rolls through maricopa county
the cities
and uh governing energies entities the
county spends hundreds of thousands of
dollars to convince ca and the epa that
that was a so-called exceptional event
and not as a result of pollution that
occurs from man-made sources the epa
knows this but still we have to go
through the exercise every time one of
these dust storms occurs and they occur
frequently every couple of weeks in the
summer time
another example in northern arizona
there's a power plant a coal-fired power
plant
that powers
a good chunk of well
most of that power is used to pump the
water from the colorado river that feeds
a lot of central arizona very important
source of power for us
it complies and has been made to comply
with every epa mandate out there in
terms of clean air at great expense to
the ratepayers and the people of arizona
but the epa came and said that's not
good enough uh
there's
we we want to look at visibility even
though there was no congressional
prerogative or no law that said that
he said we want to make sure
that it's not negatively impacting
visibility in the national parks like
the grand canyon
now so they conducted some studies and
found that uh
that even after spending billions of
dollars
there would not be a perceptible change
in any visibility standards the wind
typically blows the other way
uh but that didn't stop them and so
they're looking for ways to shut this
power plant down and that's what they've
chosen to do
so the these agencies are certainly out
of control
congress needs to reinvigorate and i can
see no better way than for us to to
have a project like this and i command
mike lee and others for
for
envisioning this and for hillsdale for
hosting today
and it's a pleasure to be with
so many people here that i know and
admire and respect on this issue so
thanks for having me here
uh we have time for uh questions from
the the three these three speakers
before we go to our panels if uh we have
some please uh raise a hand
uh general right here
uh and we have a microphone coming so we
can pick up the audio thank you very
much
um the um
article one section one says all powers
shall be bested that few powers not some
powers not many powers and doesn't say
could be vested may be invested is that
is that how you saw the founding fathers
writing it and is that an argument you
all can use to restore article one
section one
yes absolutely i mean
if there's one encapsulation of the
article one project it's that
um i i
wrote a book about this a few months ago
it's called our lost constitution i have
a very significant section of the book
devoted specifically to that point
it is no accident that the first
operative provision of the constitution
the first clause of the first section of
the first article says that all
legislative powers here and granted
shall be vested in the congress
and uh
we have uh reconstrued that
so that we say in effect some of it may
be vested in a constitution that's
really the way it operates today the
important thing to remember is that this
is of our own making sometimes when you
hear members of congress talking about
over-regulation and excessive executive
discretion
they speak about it as if we were
somehow the victims in this we're the
perpetrators we designed it that way
members of congress are less accountable
when it works that way and that's what
we have to turn around
um we're here
paul ryan speaker of the house has
indicated in the spring we expect to see
a bold new initiative
related to this re-establishing
congress's power the purse hopefully
that would be addressed in the panel
discussion as what we might expect in
the spring about the budget and
the power of the purse that congress
needs to reassert itself with
hold on that one or
well as the house guy although not the
speaker guy i know this is very
important to our new speaker i hope in
many respects that uh the article one
project and what the speaker has in mind
will dovetail but we recently came
uh from our uh
republican retreat and again i know this
is huge priority with speakers a huge
priority with our entire house
republican conference is represented by
a number of our members here today
so all i can say is um stay tuned look
forward
in the back
let's get back here
he's waiting back there
uh thank you so much all of us are very
concerned and you mentioned the power of
the purse but of course congress isn't
only spending money it keeps creating
new bureaucracies there's one i've been
watching because i very much care about
what's happening on college campuses
right now
with the department of education
destroying due process imposing
ideologies on campus senator gillibrand
is pushing one called the campus
accountability and safety act which does
nothing to stop sexual assaults
all it does is create more bureaucracy
more power more imposition of ideology
more control over the campuses
and what i'm hearing is that senator
alexander is saying he's not getting
enough opposition from republicans he
may just put it in the higher education
reauthorization act
somebody needs to stop the creation of
new bureaucracies that goes beyond
reducing the funding of existing
bureaucracies so can anybody address how
you're going to stop that particular new
bureaucracy from being created
i've not been following that one
specifically but maybe my cash
i i learned about this a few weeks ago
this is news to me that he's thinking
about putting it in the higher education
reauthorization act i'm glad to know
that
i have some major concerns with it and
how it would affect due process the due
process rights of uh
of the accused so yeah that's a big
problem i think you also raise a very
good
underlying point which is that in
addition to reforming the process moving
forward to make sure that we
go through congress to make laws
we we first ought to stop the the
bloodletting we first opt to stop the
wound close the wound so we don't expand
um the regulatory process and create
more outsourcing of legislative power
and your point that when new entities
are created
um
then we're going the wrong direction
that is certainly the case uh when these
uh entities
are created then they feed on themselves
and uh they require more regulations to
exist and
it just rolls and how many times do we
ever go in
and uh extinguish one of these agencies
or sub-agencies or offices
so it is it's a growing problem
man if i could i just i have vote
starting in committee in 15 minutes i'm
gonna have to excuse myself and as
chairman of the committee i was the guy
who called the vote so it'd be really
embarrassing to be late so then i have
to excuse myself thank you very much for
being here thank you
right here
hi
this one kevin costa of the r street
institute i've written a bit on
restoring congress as the first branch
and one of the problems it seems to me
is that when you look at the size of the
two branches over the last 100 years the
size of congress in terms of the number
of people working for it
the appropriations for it the support
staff etc etc has grown a bit
but relative to the executive branch
it's nothing
and so there's a basic structural
imbalance there
oversight is hard when you don't have
enough eyes
do you see
beefing up congress as an institution
more people
you know more research
etc etc as part of the project
okay so that's an interesting question i
i the short answer to that question is i
don't think that hiring more people in
congress hiring more staff in congress
is necessarily the answer there i i
think there's a lot more we could do
with the personnel that we have if we
just do our jobs if we just do what
we're supposed to do
but your question brings to mind
a more basic point um
which i'm glad you've raised which is
that
the people depicted in the painting
behind us
did not envision
what we have today
they did envision the risk that the
chief executive could become
too powerful
and even though they saw george
washington as the heir apparent to
article two
they saw george washington i i don't
think they ever envisioned anyone other
than george washington being our first
president there was no more respected
man in the world certainly no more
respected man in the western hemisphere
than george washington they trusted him
implicitly he was after all uh
rather unprecedented in having wielded
tremendous authority in the
revolutionary war he won the revolution
and then he voluntarily relinquished
power at the end of the war
notwithstanding the respect they had in
him and the trust they had in him
they still made
the presidency relatively weak
they hindered his power
they made it really
hard for him to
become anything resembling a king and
yet we've somehow managed to undo that
they put all the power in congress the
only reason the executive branch is so
much more bloated than we are so much
more powerful than we are is because we
have made it that way and that's why we
have to turn it around we can do that
without an army of staff that rivals the
executive branch of government in size i
would agree with that we obviously have
to have the resources to conduct
oversight and we try to utilize them to
the fullest some of our staff are here
and they'll attest to that
but
what we need is a process
when we find all right here's what this
agency is doing
they shouldn't be doing or here's this
project that shouldn't have been
approved it was never authorized uh we
have to have a process that allows us to
go politically
and and say we're going to
cut funding for that or direct it
elsewhere and when you just have one
bill at the end of the year a big
omnibus you forfeit that right uh if for
no other reason politically it just
can't be done and so that's why the
reforms to our budget process um and
actually following even the budget
process we have if we were to do that
would give us a lot more power
we're going to take one more question
with these uh senators and we'll
continue with our other panels way in
the back
last year a different group called the
article 5 project gain traction texas
governor greg abbott is one of the
excuse me one of the forces behind that
and the
it has the same goal which is to limit
the power of the executive but to do so
with a constitutional amendment ratified
by the state legislatures
so in in what way is the article 1
project meant to be a response to the
article 5 project
speaking for myself i can say not at all
it's not a response to
anything other than the constitution
itself and the fact that we've deviated
from it substantially over the last
century mostly over the last 80 years
um i
i i think that if we followed the
constitution as it's set up
it it would help us restore what needs
to be restored
and um
and if i if i can speak to this uh the
the point um that we were bringing up at
the end of the last
question about the budgeting process i
agree with everything senator flake
said and i would add to it
that regardless of
how many appropriations bills we have
regardless of whether we follow
the budget act as outlined in 1974 and
whether we have a dozen bills the
12 appropriations bill formula
was not carved into stone
uh
without hands and handed down on tablets
um there's nothing magical about the
number 12.
to me it'd be great to follow
that formula
but
to me the far more important part of the
budgeting and appropriations process is
that we have debate deliberation and
most importantly opportunity for
amendment
in other words
i'd rather have
one or two or three bills
that spend money with an open unlimited
amendment process shoot i'd rather have
one single appropriations bill as long
as members had an equal open opportunity
to amend that to debate it in public and
to discuss it
then i would have 12 bills where it's
brought to the floor
uh and we're told you've got a binary
choice on this either pass it and you
fund it or you vote no and that's it
i'd like to add to that or no no just
that uh you know the beauty of this
project is we're not envisioning any
constitutional amendment that would be
needed we're just talking about
returning to
what was intended in the constitution
that's right i would just add
as a matter of record there's nothing
proposed on the article 5 process that
can't be done with a stronger congress
that passes laws and executive detective
executes and judiciary that adjudicates
under the constitution uh thank you
general we're going to turn off this
over to jim capretta who's going to
organize our first panel thank you
uh well good morning uh my name is jim
capretta i'm a
fellow visiting fellow at the american
enterprise institute and a senior fellow
at the ethics and public policy center
and i'm very pleased to welcome up to
the podium the panel here um we have
representative barry loudermilk from
georgia
representative dave bratt
from the 7th district of virginia
representative mia love from the 4th
district of utah
and representative gary palmer from the
6th district of alabama
i will make a couple of very brief
remarks and then we will turn to each of
them as they get settled here
uh to talk about the issue that's been
come coming up repeatedly as the
conversation is proceeded this morning
on the power of the purse
uh it's obvious to me i've been working
in budgeting uh
perhaps i need to make a confession here
that i did work in the executive branch
and i worked on budgeting in the
executive branch at the office of
management and budget
and uh that regard required me to
oversee quite a bit of spending and i
think a lot of the criticisms that have
been made about the process are
actually very very accurate
and so uh
this power of the purse
that is uh the subject of this panel
is probably the
number one issue that needs to be
addressed there's so much decision
making that is
now
reduced to just a few people at the end
of the year
in closed rooms
with little accountability
and no process for the public to see it
through their representatives eyes and
so
so much of it feels like it's broken and
many
ideas are starting to bubble up to try
to
begin to address it and so let's uh
let's get started on that by turning
uh first
uh
to representative mia love we'll have
her go first
and describe some of her thinking around
this subject and
we will then proceed to the other
panelists in turn
thank you
powerful wow
it's still very loud
okay there we go there you go okay um so
thank you uh for allowing me to be here
today i'm really excited about this
project and um
certainly excited about the prospect of
restoring restoring article one of
the constitution back um to the united
states government uh
one of the things that senator mike lee
talked about was um
excluding the american people
in from the process
uh
one of the issues that i believe that
has made it very difficult and has
excluded the american people
are these large
must-pass bills at the 11th hour some of
them actually on autopilot
and one of the frustrations that i have
is all of the other
pieces of legislation that's tacked on
to the must-pass bills pieces of
legislation that congress can't read let
alone the american people so that they
can actually let their
their representatives know exactly uh
what is going on it's really interesting
with a just kind of
my thinking is getting back to the
process what i've realized is every vote
that we take really doesn't matter
unless we restore the constitution
back
into into our government
i
dropped a bill that i actually thought
would uh go nowhere um it's one subject
at a time bill just to kind of see if we
can clear the air a little bit and allow
the american people to be part of the
process again allow our
allow for us to talk about bills to vote
down bills without holding hostage our
military without holding hostage to
things that we actually should be um
legislating on which is which is our
military and and some of the few
um
powers that are or i should say issues
that
washington should be taking care of very
limited um
pieces of legislation really interesting
is that
i started i dropped this bill and i
started uh messaging out to utah and i
found that it's actually
spread like wildfire
not just um conservatives that are
really uh attaching themselves to this
bill but liberals on the other end that
are tired of their representatives
voting for legislation that they don't
want them to vote talk about getting
back accountability again there's no
reason why we should vote for a highway
bill attached to xm there's no reason
why we should have these large must pass
bills where you have a speaker of the
house that says we should pass it before
we understand what's in it
that is not how government was meant
that's not how we um our uh government
was set up so
i have to go to those markups by the way
by um chairman left those markups but i
believe that there's good news here so i
believe that this bill is actually
getting some legs not by congress but
the american people which will force
congress to hopefully get this bill to
the floor but it'll start to clear the
way and restoring the constitution i
want to warn everyone that restoring the
constitution especially article one of
the constitution doesn't mean that we
will not make
mistakes that's not what that means it's
far from it as a matter of fact our
country has made many mistakes but it
allows us that when we do make the
mistakes and when government starts to
reign over the american people
under the large umbrella of the
constitution we have the ability the
people have the ability to restore that
to fix that problem
and so i i want you to know i'm excited
i've got a lot of hope for this country
because the people that are sitting next
to me and the people that are that um
that are working in in congress i have
to let you know that there are some
great people there and i'm honored to be
part of this process it's our
responsibility to make sure that we
preserve this great country for all of
our children especially my three that
are at home that are expecting me to do
something about it so i want to thank
you
thank my senator uh mike lee for
involving me in this project he's a
great partner and um
i'm excited about it thank you so much
thank you
we'll turn now to uh congressman
loudermilk who has been very very active
on these questions has a few ideas
around he's got a lot of ideas as a
matter of fact in this area and so why
don't i just turn it over to you
congressman to
talk for a few minutes and we'll go down
to the panel after that well thank you
let me first
thank senator mike lee for including me
in this in fact uh i showed him after uh
the state of the union uh i happen to
have a copy of his book regarding a
balanced budget uh with me on the floor
i found that as more interesting reading
than what i was hearing coming from the
rostrum so um
and purposely sat where i wouldn't be on
the camera so uh
as others i've i've been sitting out
here looking at this painting and what
intrigues me about this painting
is that you see
these founders these framers in action
they're not sitting at a table
they're not uh just
sitting there with one person in debate
but they're caucusing they're discussing
they're working
i think it's it it sort of reflects what
you see but in a more chaotic way what
happens every day on the floor of the
house of representatives
because there's work being done
the other thing that struck me was uh
something that
gave me an answer this morning as i was
sitting out there one of the criticisms
that
i have heard from members of congress
and also
members of the press and others if you
look at the makeup
of this article one project the majority
of the members are freshmen members of
congress
the majority of the panels there's we do
have the the experience and leadership
of some that have been here for a while
in both houses but the majority makeup
is freshmen
and the criticism is how are you guys
going to be able to fix this problem
well as i was sitting out there and
looking at this painting it dawned on me
only only five people up there
in that painting were there
when they signed the declaration of
independence
these this wasn't the continental
congress they were meeting elsewhere
these were representatives from the
states that brought in the ideas and the
concerns that the states and those
people of the states and the state
legislatures would have about building
a government that could grow into a very
powerful government and that was their
greatest fear one thing
these founders understood they
understood human nature they also
understood the potential of the growth
of government if it was not constrained
and so while they may have envisioned
where that we wouldn't be in the
position we are today as a culture as a
society they did understand
that if we didn't constrain the
government the government would be in a
position that it was today and and
of executive overreach because if you go
back and you look at the declaration of
independence
in the declaration of independence
there's 27 grievances and all the
grievances are grievances against
executive overreach
ironically when you read it the first
seven there are many more but the first
seven actually address
overreach of legislative powers it shows
how important this was to our founders
not only did our constitution set a
framework that constrained the power of
a federal government
it also put into place the ability
for the most
accountable and directly responsible to
the people branch of this government
to hold the other branches accountable
and the way they did they they framed
that is through the power of the purse
one of the problems we're facing today
is there isn't a single purse
their idea was that congress would
control the power of a purse
when you look at what's happening in
many of the departments many of the
agencies
some of them are becoming closer and
closer to being self-funded through fees
and penalties and fines
that they claim are outside the reach of
the appropriations process of congress
that's one of the areas that we have to
address
the other thing that the founders
envisioned is that this congress
or any congress or the legislative
branch would also know where the money
is being spent
knowledge is power but ignorance is
weakness
i think congress has become very
ignorant of exactly where the money is
being spent once it is is appropriated
to various agencies
many years ago there was something that
we are wanting to look at uh as as part
of this article one project there was
something that was known as the bird
commission
it preceded uh well the bird commission
was uh
were given the responsibility as a as a
a committee with the subpoena power to
be able to go in and look deep do deep
diving into every appropriations to find
out where there's duplication where
there's fraud where there's waste
and where we're spending money on
projects that we'd no longer need to
spend money these are the types of
things that we need to be doing
in congress today is doing some deep
diving going into the details looking
for areas of fraud waste abuse but also
duplication of services these are the
things that many of our state
legislatures are doing
they have a single a single purse in
fact uh when i served in the state of
georgia
one of the issues that often faced those
who just wanted to
raise taxes that were specifically for
some type of type of project were always
frustrated because the constitution of
the state of georgia specified
that all revenues
went into the treasury to be
appropriated by the legislature all
revenues regardless of how those
revenues were received if they were by
fine or they were by penalty or they
were for a fee
all revenues went into the legislature
of course the special interest had major
issues with that because they wanted
their fee for tire disposal to go to
environmental issues
and they did not want that left just to
the whims of the legislative body but
the whims of the legislative body are to
be reflective of the culture and the
will of the people
these are just some of the areas that i
think that it is important for to us
address early we have several other
ideas but i don't want to dominate the
time here because this is something that
is very important i have
i have a one and a half year old
granddaughter
and every time i hold her and i play
with her i think
she deserves better
than what we're passing along to to our
next generation she deserves much better
these guys intended that each generation
would be would be better off than the
previous generation right now americans
don't feel that that's the case
but we have the opportunity as they did
to make a change to affect change
to actually bring some common sense
restoration
of our constitutional powers
to this body
and
to make the american people feel
that they have some power as we as their
representative bodies as they will be
able to hold us accountable
with an 18 trillion dollar debt and
growing
we have to change the way we do business
and again i think senator mike lee for
the vision to do this
next we'll turn to congressman brad
please christine oh good well thank you
for the comments i didn't know what i
was going to say until barry teed me up
so now i got some comments
thank you very much to hillsdale and
senator mike lee for putting this
together it
couldn't have a more important topic
right now in terms of getting things
straight
the one thing we haven't weighed into it
all is politics yet
and i don't think we're going to get any
changes until the politics turns right
you're going to have to have a wave
election and the people are going to
have to put pressure on their
representatives
so all last year you can just look at
the budget process and i'll get into
that in a minute but just look at what
we're voting for
as a conservative conference and the
budget number i think the whole process
last time even by the speaker was called
the crap sandwich
everybody eating breakfast already i'm
not upsetting anyone right and cleaning
the barn and now this year we're going
to vote on that new high number again
and the senate is hinting that they're
they've already
adopted that number and then that's
going to put reverse pressure back on
the house that we're going to have to
live up to that high number
and everybody knows that the whole
debate right you got 70 percent of
republicans voting for outsider
candidates right now for a reason
they're very upset
and why is that because they know the
american people aren't getting
represented at all
so i even asked bernie sanders the other
day at the white house christmas party i
went up to him i said hey i'm not
putting you on the spot
and uh you know i'm just gonna ask you a
question i said up here
i said everybody in the press and
everybody wants this horse race story
what do you think of paul ryan this kind
of thing and it's about conservatives
versus liberals i said my experience up
here in one year it's not about that at
all
i said it's about the middle
that has conspired to increase budgets
to three and a half trillion dollars a
year and that pressure of all the
special interest comes down on paul
ryan's head and no single person is
strong enough to withstand that pressure
right especially when you have the whole
conference making deals and special
interest projects and everybody's
representing their people and needs
something special in their state or
wherever
it's tremendous pressure
and so that's the politics in a rough
way
i don't have any stats on this painting
behind me other than to say they're all
virginians right so i'm from virginia
sorry son not at all i i just want to
get my alabama colleagues
riled up
uh anyway i gave my announcement speech
back when i ran a couple years ago at st
john's church patrick henry
james madison
i wrote the constitution is in from my
district
uh i went to princeton seminary he went
to roughly princeton seminary when he
graduated from the college of jersey he
took hebrew just for kicks
right for a year
so when you talk about the world view
that informed the constitution
it's a particular world view
and it's a particular world view that
may not be informing the american people
right now right the judeo-christian
tradition
and the inherent conservatism built into
that worldview that human nature is not
utopian
uh it's
fallen
and if you don't start off with that
framework in your head you're gonna end
up with the wrong logic and the wrong
kind of document the wrong kind of
process and so thank god very brought
that up because that helped me
put that together but we need to change
that right and that has to do with k-12
education educating the kids on what
liberty is really about liberty you only
get liberty if you have the law
the liberals tend to forget that part
right you get liberty because
we tell the government what they cannot
do
uh and so let's just get to the budget
to show you how serious this is so we've
heard all the numbers the
uh debt is now up to 19 trillion the
deficit this year
is going up to about 530
billion
uh under republican leadership of the
house and the senate we're increasing
the deficit this year by a hundred
billion we're increasing the deficit by
a hundred billion this year
so if any of you want to help get that
out to the people that might inform
their view of how we're doing up here
right so the deficit's 500 billion by
2022 it'll be a trillion a year
the deficit the amount we're adding to
the debt going forward so we'll get to
30 trillion within no time
right so that's when china's having a
hiccup right now because they're at two
times
debt to gdp right two or three times
we're one time right we're 19 trillions
about the same size the economy so
they're i'm gonna hiccup major hiccup
they may not
come out of it and greece is way past
that and that's where
that's where we are in terms of debt
load more serious than that the unfunded
liabilities are 100 trillion
right that's the amount we've promised
to pay in law in the mandatory spending
stuff that we have given up our power to
control oversight everything
two-thirds of the budget is that right
now in 11 years
all federal revenues
will go to
unfunded liabilities mandatory programs
and interest on the debt
in 11 years there won't be one dollar
left for national defense education
transportation or running government in
11 years
so anyone that doesn't think this is
timely
you're not paying attention to the
numbers in 11 years it's all over
and i don't know if we can turn around
right you're gonna have to have the will
of the people somehow
grasp that vote against their own
self-interest rediscover a thing called
discipline
and we're gonna ask voters to vote for
that right here take some bad taste in
medicine it's for your own good
that's what we're that's what we're
facing right we have to convince a
majority of people to take bad taste in
medicine
and there's no way around that
uh
votes uh
in the concrete
there's tremendous pressure on us in the
conference to vote for everything that
sounds good
last year we had a thing called the
cures act to help kids with cancer
voted against it
you're not laughing you can laugh this
is that was a joke right my brother does
a neural path down to emory his inbox
was flooded what the hell is your
brother doing up there he's right
i voted against it because we created a
new mandatory program we're already 100
trillion light
and the republicans created a new
mandatory program to fund the cures act
so i said fine i'm nuking it put in the
brat amendment my brother's last name
was brat so it wasn't a pleasant day for
him
right
and that's that so but it all sounds
good are we going to vote yes take the
easy way out in conference yep yep yep
yep if you vote yup yup yup
you get the problems i just said
tremendous pressure on all of us so we
need pressure coming back from you to
solve the problem
uh paul ryan to his credit we're doing
regular order
the house freedom caucus
and senator lee and a bunch of other
support have come in on that
project that's the biggest
progress we've made
right that commitment to regular order
and the appropriations process
but keep your eye on that ball i'm not
optimistic as to the outcome of the
approach process this year already from
what i'm here right so keep your eye on
us hold us accountable and i'll just end
it right there i probably went on too
long thank you thank you congressman
that's very good uh last but surely not
least congressman gary palmer from
alabama's sixth district
dave gets on me all the time about not
smiling much after hearing that do you
know why
um
okay i'm gonna be brief
i
some of you know i ran a think tank for
25 years i've worked with matt for years
uh
with because of some of the a lot of
what i've read that matt's written i
have a very clear understanding of of
how our system's supposed to operate
and uh very touched on something about
the unappropriated funds so i'm just
going to get to some ideas is this off
the record or is it going to be on fox
news tonight
yeah okay so so i'm going to fix my own
crap sandwich
um
i'm introducing a bill that will
prohibit
any funds uh unappropriated funds for
going to any federal agency
all of the funds will go into the
general treasury this is something i've
been uh working on since i've i've
gotten here
uh and but they will be identified with
the agency where
where they originated and one of my
biggest uh issues is with the consumer
financial protection board that gets its
funding all of its funding
from the fed
congress loses all oversight
we lose we completely lose the power of
the purse when we allow agencies to
collect unappropriated funds so these
funds
in this bill will go to the general
treasury identified with the agency then
it'll be up to the
appropriating subcommittee's
jurisdiction to to appropriate that
money back home if they deem it's worth
it we've also got a change in my opinion
how we appropriate and i'm working on
other legislation
that uh right now if this
if this cup were an agency budget
it's like a silo come october first we
fill it up
uh they spend it through september 30th
and october 1st we fill that thing up
again
we lose all ability
to have any oversight
control over the appropriation once it
goes into the silo when we try to walk
it back what do they say you're shutting
down the government
so what i'm recommending is that we
change our appropriation process we will
appropriate an amount that will fill the
silo
but we will
give treasury directions to only release
a quarter of it at a time with
instructions from congress and here's
why
when the executive branch doesn't carry
out the mandates of congress doesn't
implement the laws that we pass which by
the way matt i think is part of the oath
isn't it that that he will execute uh
faithfully execute the laws of congress
if they don't do that if an agency's not
doing what they're supposed to do we can
the next quarter direct the treasury to
withhold say 50 million dollars
now that that is
not even a rounding air in the budget it
doesn't shut down the government but it
holds that agency accountable if the
next quarter they still haven't done
what they're supposed to do we withhold
75 or 100 million we can make it painful
they'd start laying off people and
frankly i think we don't have to do that
four or five times
before everybody would get the message
and it would restore congressional
oversight over
federal agencies that's how you regain
the power of the purse
the other issue that we don't talk about
a lot
is regulatory reform
and it is the secret path to
appropriations
uh federal agencies are making rules
they're implementing them to the to the
tune of two trillion dollars
now that's what regulations cost our
economy last year was two trillion
dollars that's 15 000 per household
we need to break down the regulatory
reform process into component parts
uh and i you know if it's
regulations
related to community banks we need to
have a a a working group that's just
focused on community banks with
community bankers actually in the
process regulators under the oversight
of congress get rid of the obsolete get
rid of the duplications get the
regulations that we're going to keep and
simplify them so that the regulators
actually understand what the regulations
say themselves because frankly a lot of
them don't and it's killing business in
the u s and it's a hidden cost it's not
a hidden tax the tax actually goes to
support some government program at some
level this doesn't support anything
uh
and the impact that's having on the
economy is enormous in 2008 there were
100 000 more businesses started up and
closed in 2013 there were 70 000 more
businesses closed and started up
in terms of entrepreneurism we rank 12th
in the world now we're behind hungry so
we gotta we got to take that on that's
part of congress restoring its oversight
authority
i think we've got to define agency
jurisdictions better
i've got a bill
stopping epa overreach that that
declares uh
that the epa does not have the authority
to regulate greenhouse gases
okay
most people don't think this is a battle
over climate change okay or over the
clean power plan maybe so but what it's
really about
is reasserting congressional authority
to make law
and i've urged my colleagues on other
committees of jurisdiction to look at
the agencies under their committees
for examples of of of overstepping their
authority and introduce a two or three
page bill that simply says you do
congress never gave you that authority
so we've got to take back our law making
authority
we've also got to take responsibility
for for what we allow the agencies to do
and i think the reins act is is is a key
key
part of that
and i think most you're familiar with
but if you're not it simply says that if
any any new rule from an agency that has
an economic impact of plus or minus 100
million dollars has to go up to both
houses of congress and be passed and
signed by the president
um those are just some
some ideas that i've thrown out there
that i think make sense i think we also
ought to have i'm working on legislation
right now
that um
on on some tax issues and and and on how
we do some budgeting
but um
i don't get some i i understand the
philosophical basis for what we ought to
be doing but i think that we can talk
that till we're blue in the face makes
us look real smart and intelligent and
all that crap
what we need to do is get out there with
real solutions and
and i think time is short we got 10
years maybe to get this straightened out
or we're going to be right where my
colleague dave brett says we're heading
thank you
thank you
i think we're we're out of time at this
point so i will uh
ask my colleague yval the van to come up
and introduce the next panel on
regulatory accountability
good morning everybody um
the last panel not only ended on a very
cheerful note but it also ended uh
on more or less the subject we're going
to take up now which is the question of
the regulatory state so i want to first
call up the panel uh
three great members of the house uh
representative cynthia lummus of uh
wyoming uh mark walker of north carolina
john ratcliffe of texas why don't you
come up and i'll uh say a few words
while you get yourself settled
i want to first of all thank everybody
that's uh involved in in making this
happen senator lee and uh
his colleagues in the senate all the
members of the house are doing this it's
just enormously important
uh that this conversation happened quite
apart from what immediately comes of it
on the floor uh where individual ideas
go and i do think some of these will go
far
having this conversation raising these
questions is enormously important and
i'm very grateful also to be uh part of
uh of of starting this conversation with
you today and to be invited to be part
of this launch
in a sense our conversation this morning
is about a question that everybody uh
takes up and you can you could imagine
if you just watched washington from a
distance
everybody kind of agrees about which is
that congress is dysfunctional right
almost no one would say no no no
congress is in great great shape but
what does it mean to say congress is
dysfunctional what is the function that
it is failing to perform i think too
often when people say congress is
dysfunctional what they really just mean
is it's not passing the laws that i
would like
and a lot of these debates are not about
institutional change but are about
policy preferences
but there is one function of the
congress that ought to stand above
partisan politics and that ought to
stand above policy debates and that is
the fundamental function of the congress
in our constitutional system
the role of the congress in keeping that
system balanced and in in playing in in
using its powers in using uh its
authority to keep that system in check
and in that respect is just no question
that congress is dysfunctional it is not
performing its most basic function in
the constitutional system it's not using
the legislative authority that it's
granted uh and
the the the subject of this second panel
gets right to the heart of that question
it is really about how congress can
wrestle back some of the power uh that
the executive has taken or that as
several members have said uh this
morning in many cases the congress has
given over to the other branches of
government uh and so we're especially
concerned here with regulatory power
with reigning in the regulatory state
uh the article one project
proposes a number of different kinds of
steps to start taking some of that power
back a regulatory budget changes uh in
the administrative procedure act the
reins act civil service reforms we're
going to discuss all of those and we'll
talk about a little bit the the general
vision of the role of the congress in
what has become
uh an out-of-control administrative
state so why don't we start uh as the
last panel did with some uh remarks from
the members if we have time after that
we'll also get to some questions uh and
and hear about what concerns you all and
we'll begin with uh with representative
lumpus
oh thank you so much and uh thank you
senator lee for putting this project
together and
including so many of us to participate
i'm going to talk specifically about
regulatory overreach and mission creep
by the executive branch
in the area of public lands
i'm currently the chairman of the house
western caucus
where we're very concerned about the
administration's
overreach in regulatory issues affecting
those lands now recall
the federal government is the largest
landowner in the united states it
controls a third of the land in the
united states
six times the size
of the state of california over 90
percent of those lands are
in the west
now most of them were set aside
under a law called flippman the federal
land policy and management act in 1976
for multiple uses meaning they could be
used for recreation uh for conservation
for sensible natural resource
development whether it was mining oil
and gas
uh grazing uh and logging
but between this
executive overreach and this barrage of
regulations for example the epa's new
waters of the u.s rule
they are usurping
what was never meant to be
an issue of federal control
the waters in the united states
particularly in the west have always
been
at the province of the states
pursuant to the 10th amendment
and the constitution makes clear that
states
have that right
however under the waters of the u.s rule
they have usurped control
down to the puddle
in states
in my own state of wyoming
there is a couple
husband and wife who got a
permit from the state of wyoming to
legally
uh build a pond on their property
and the epa came in
and is finding them
thousands tens of thousands of dollars
under this new rule it is absolutely
uh beyond belief even
in this age of regulatory overreach that
this kind of thing could happen
of course
states have sued
the courts are
holding this
regulation at bay
until it is determined
whether it was properly implemented and
whether it is regulatory overreach
but it shouldn't have to go that far
let me tell you about another law
where overreach is just run amok
and that is the antiquities act of 1906.
does anybody in this room know what that
is
okay one hand
the antiquities act gives the president
the right to proclaim monuments on
federal land
that contain and this is the statutory
language historic landmarks historic and
prehistoric structures and other objects
of historic or scientific interests so
the law was originally designed
to protect quickly federal lands where
archaeological sites were being affected
by theft and looting
of course theodore roosevelt uh was uh
among the first uh to use this act
effectively now here's further statutory
language by law
designations of monuments
shall be confined to the smallest area
compatible with proper care and
management of the objects to be
protected once again
smallest area compatible
with proper care and management of the
objects to be protected
now some monuments are less than an acre
being consistent with the statutory
objective
several presidents over the years
in this creeping mission
have established massive monuments
including uh
escalante staircase which is over a
million acres glacier bay over a million
acres
president obama uh recently declared the
oregon mountains desert peaks region in
new mexico a national monument and it
was originally proposed uh with the
ascent of the local legislator steve
pearce of uh new mexico
to be 55 000 acres
the president
chose to designate almost 500 000 acres
not contiguous
the largest monument on land is saint
elias covering 11 million acres
and
what's happening now is presidents are
using the antiquities act to create
multi-million acre
marine monuments
president obama added 261
million acres
to the pacific remote islands monument
using the antiquities act now let's go
back
to the language of the law
by designation
a president can use the antiquities act
to protect the smallest acre
excuse me the smallest area compatible
with proper care and management of the
objects to be protected
now in your mind is that what
261 million acres is
this is where
the executive branch overreach either
through regulation or by mission creep
is
expanding its role and of course then
the federal government you the taxpayers
have to pay
to manage those lands
uh in a way
uh that is extremely costly and never
contemplated
by the budgeters
and the appropriators and the taxpayers
this is the kind of egregious assault
on the law and the regulations and the
constitution
that i believe senator lee wishes to
address
uh and i once again want to thank him
for his uh extraordinary vision uh in
taking this project on at this time
thank
you thank you very much congressman
radcliffe
well this morning
before you speak i am i'm sorry but i'm
going to have to slip i'm speaking at a
keynote address in about uh 15-20
minutes over heritage would you like to
go first thirty i didn't wanna yeah go
ahead please well just maybe two or
three minutes said sorry for the
inconvenience john thank you
we talked a lot about today
about the nuts and bolts of what the
problems are this we're preaching to the
choir today
uh as we transition and one of the
things that i respect about this it's
it's not a design to talk about the what
but the how how do we effectively
communicate the change that is necessary
and that is where the people come in you
know i think of this in a couple
approaches there's a vertical approach
of where we're being intentional
and holding washington accountable
political organizations those who want
to strip us or
of our liberties that we continue to see
eroding
and it's important we've heard much
about
anger lately have you heard about can
you be angry can you listen
patrick henry's you remember that give
me liberty give me death martin luther
said you know what i when i'm angry i
preach better i serve better keith
miller uh great author of the 20th
century
said this he said nothing in a social
change in america's history has ever
been accomplished unless the people were
angry it's okay to be angry when we're
holding people accountable when we do we
should be compassionate but there's also
that horizontal approach
where we have to be able to communicate
what's important constitutional to the
people that we live with to our
co-workers to our friends our family and
our neighbors recently i won't name a
name but there's a there's a
presidential candidate and now and i'll
put it this way as a former minister
in fact i officiated a wedding just last
saturday evening
and there's a passage there from uh
one corinthians not two corinthians uh
that uh
only been around since king james a few
hundred years but but it talks about
uh
having compassion but it talks about all
these accomplishments but it profits
nothing it uses the reference a a
clanking symbol now i've directed choirs
an orchestra as part of our ministry
background clanging symbol is pretty
much worthless
but it's but it's the loudest instrument
so i thought about this you know if you
don't know between the difference
between
one corinthians and two corinthians do
you know the difference between article
one and article two
it's okay to be a loud voice
as long as you're doing more than just
making noise
and that's why i have thoroughly enjoyed
partnering with senator mike lee see
there's a difference between just being
conservative
but being an effective conservative and
that's where all of our roles come
together to be an effective conservative
we have to communicate these topics
aren't making the front page of the wall
street journal or time magazine or
anything else it is our responsibility
to talk about the importance of why we
hold the constitution and why it's
important when it comes to the
governance or body wish i had more time
to share but i am i think i'm on stage
in just a few minutes i want to thank
again senator mike lee certainly i want
to thank the wonderful people here at
hillsdale for the great privilege to
partner with you guys thank you so much
thank you
we'll try again
you know this morning um
you've heard from some of the leading
voices of conservatism
um that have spoken eloquently about
our founders and their vision and our
need to reclaim that vision
i wish i could be that guy but that's
not really who i am the perspective that
i can give you is is one as a new member
of congress and um
someone who
now representing
750 000
americans in my case 750 000 people in
east texas
um hears frequently
from my constituents
when are you guys going to stand up to
the president
when is congress going to do that when
is when is congress going to stand up to
federal agencies when is congress going
to do something
that's really the issue that that we're
all um you know hearing in our districts
and you know you can give a a real sort
of nuanced answer that part of it
relates to uh
60 vote you know cloture rule in the
senate or
other types of excuses
but the real answer is the one that
senator lee talked about
at the outset of this is that
congress needs to reclaim its its power
you know when the senator asked me to
get involved in this um
project he said something that struck me
he said we need to
reconstitutionalize washington
and that's really what um
what this is about congress i'm getting
back to to its role and it's not just
the power of the purse
um
as you've heard from
cynthia's remarks
and others here you know
um congress under our constitution as we
all know is to be the sole lawmaker in
our in our federal government and
the bottom line is today most laws are
not being passed by congress
most laws today are really being imposed
by unelected unaccountable bureaucrats
in different federal agencies cynthia
you talked about the you know waters of
the u.s that's a you know that's a
perfect example um
you know of an agency just suddenly
changing an interpretation of what main
waterways of the u.s the definition of
that is to include adjacent bodies which
can be um can mean the streams and
ditches that are you know in our own
backyards and
um that really wasn't the
congressional intent behind that and the
the problem that we've had is you know
as the son of school as the son of two
school teachers is we all learn that we
have three separate but equal branches
of government and maybe that's how it
was intended to be and maybe that's how
it generally has operated but
um
things have occurred along the way as
everyone here has highlighted where
we've gotten away from that and so you
know what this project gives us an
opportunity to do is to focus on those
things so for instance in you know one
of the
impacts
to that
respect is a supreme court case in 1984
the chevron case and
um essentially those of you that
familiar with it um you know essentially
says that if there's a congressional
statute that has any ambiguity in it
agencies are allowed to apply any
reasonable interpretation to that and so
long as it's reasonable
they're able to do that and the end
result is for every law that congress
creates those agencies go out
and create regulations which really have
the effect of law and so
you know one of the pride one of the
things that i'd like to focus on here is
the initiative there is how can we
reform the
the chevron deference as its caller the
chevron two step um because that's one
of the things that's contributed to this
um
you know disparity in in power between
um article one and article two
um as it's currently operating in our
federal government so
um
there's there's so many uh exciting
initiatives uh that we can approach uh
together i'm again grateful to be here
this morning um and to be part of the
project and appreciate senator lee uh
allowing me to part of be part of his
vision
well great thank you very much thank you
both very much we have a few minutes for
questions um if anybody's got a burning
question uh please wait for the mic yeah
please wait for the mic
thank you
couple of um
comments and a question
uh we have um
a number of presidential candidates
certainly on on both sides
and
we're hearing what they are going to do
and we're not
getting any
uh inclination on the part of those
candidates to
include the congress in their
activities
and one of the things i think we need to
be careful about even in in prayerful
anticipation that we have a
republican
in the office
is to
hold
that person accountable
uh and not let them run away with the um
with the store
uh what and and senator lee probably you
know this applies to all the panels i
think
and um what what are we prepared to do
when
our president uh
seems to be willing to run away with the
uh with its store
yeah this brings up a very important
question it's easy for us as
conservatives now to see the dangers of
executive power because we don't like
what this particular executive wants to
do
would we be in the same place with a
republican president and isn't that
really part of why this project has to
start now
either of you wants to
well
going back to the subject that i chose
to focus on even president george w bush
designated an 89 million acre
national monument in the
in the marines i mean in the ocean
uh so
it is not just democrats uh that are
exercising this extraordinary expansion
uh of federal overreach
and congress should have rained him in
and prevented that kind of overreach
when we allow those things to
uh occur
without reining in and exercising our
article one powers we're giving tacit
approval uh to the ever creeping mission
uh of a bloated and irresponsible
bureaucracy
um so
we have abrogated over the years as a
congress
our mission
i i had endorsed
for president
senator rand paul in part because
he had expressed an interest in serving
as a president who would cede power back
to congress
he wanted to use uh what has become uh
presidential and executive overreach
to
restore
article one powers to congress
and
i would
and he unfortunately
may not have the opportunity to do that
given the current state of play in the
presidential elections but i would hope
that some of his
fellow candidates for president
uh would choose to
exercise that part of his agenda uh and
help restore to the people of this
country
um
the opportunity
to
set their own destiny through their
elected officials
i
would certainly echo
the comments from uh cynthia but uh
and primarily to the point that you know
the article one project isn't um
about partisanship it's about
constitutionalism and so to give you an
example of of the reforms that we need
to do applying regardless of a
republican or a democrat administration
is
um
statistically there's a an aberration
that occurs at the end of every
administration republican and democrat
a mad rush of what are called midnight
regulations from the time that um
a new president is elected till the time
that the outgoing president
leaves that period of time there's a
surge of regulations where folks are
concerned about legacy issues and
and that happens at the end of uh every
administration republican and democrat
and that's
now just so happens that later this year
we're going to see that and happens to
relate to the obama administration but
historically it's happened again
regardless of party that's one of the
issues that we're focusing on
because it's a problem that um has been
a historical problem and so the one that
we're trying to fix and so i think that
really speaks to the fact that what
we're all here to do is to get back to
constitutionalism regardless of the
label that's applied to it or the party
that's affected by it
let's take one final question over here
uh thank you um uh steve klein formerly
of cheyenne wyoming and homesick um
uh
this is a at least part of this project
broadly is there do you see any room for
litigation in this i work mostly in
campaign finance law the federal
election commission has been defined by
litigation from from congress whether it
was james buckley in the seventies uh
senator mcconnell in the early two
thousands and even today uh they were
they were working to to limit the
agency's power and today we have uh
congress representatives suing for them
to expand their power congressman man
holland is in litigation right now um
particularly with with the epa there
have been great successes in the last
few years they haven't certainly been
cure alls but but even nine to nothing
opinions from the supreme court uh at
least bringing some limitations on the
powers of
epa and certain other agencies as
regards to land rights so
certainly it's something it might speak
against constitutionalism for for
article one to go ask article three for
permission for to reinforce its power
but but is there perhaps room for for
future litigation of that type against
uh these agencies for their for their uh
arbitrary uh interpretations of the law
my perspective on that is um yeah that
we we certainly want to focus on
legislative solutions here with with
respect to the art of one project but
but essentially we need to
deploy whatever tools we can
to restore a system of checks and
balances that is in place and so you
know recently the house gained standing
with respect to litigation against the
executive branch i think that's part of
the
um
one of the tools in the tool kit that
that we can use to restore that sort of
balance but but i think you know within
this project itself you know the focus
is going to be more on um on
you know legislative solutions
uh i think two things about this one is
i would like to see the area of
regulatory takings law
be more fleshed out so the president is
more clear about what constitutes a
regulatory takings
and i also
want to point out how important this
election is to the composition of the
supreme court going forward
obviously the next president is going to
be in a position to shape the court
they can shape it in a way that allows
this continued
opportunity for the executive branch to
reasonably or unreasonably interpret
legislation
or
can hold
agencies to a stricter
standard
uh by virtue of uh
their their supreme court decisions so
um an often overlooked consequence of
who we elect as president
uh this year
will be
their effect on the court and i would
encourage everyone here to
point that out
to your
fellow
voters
thank you very much let's thank our
panel i appreciate it
we'll close with just a few more words
from our host matt spalding
uh thank you i just very brief uh
comment since references have made this
made this painting several times i point
this is a particular moment the
constitutional convention uh the morning
of september 17th the document's done
the windows have been opened
madison is hamming handing washington
the pin to sign the document
in the middle benjamin franklin is
gesturing to washington's chairs famous
quotation
is that painted on the back of
washington's chair a setting sun or our
rising sun and he now knows at this very
moment that is indeed a rising sun
uh that's still true today uh not
because we hue to an old 18th century
document because this document creates
the most dynamic and greatest framework
of a self-governing society man has ever
invented and we want to recover that
dynamism for our own good in the good of
self-government thank you all for
joining us this morning and have a good
day thank you
you